اعترف الجيش الإسرائيلي
لأول مرة بأن صحفية الجزيرة
شيرين أبو عكلي قُتلت على الأرجح
بنيران إسرائيلية ،
وأصدرت قوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية تقريراً يوم الاثنين
خلص فيه إلى أن وفاة أبو عكلي
كانت حادثاً قُتلت في مايو
أثناء تغطيتها لعملية عسكرية إسرائيلية.
في الضفة الغربية ، تقول قوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية إن
هناك احتمالية كبيرة لتحملهم
المسؤولية ، لكنهم لم ينووا
متابعة اتهامات جنائية ضد
الجندي المسؤول في بيان
قال الجيش إن الجنود لم يعلموا
أنهم أطلقوا النار على الصحافة
واعتقدوا أنهم أطلقوا النار.  بالعودة إلى
أدلة المسلحين ، على الرغم من
التحقيق الذي أجرته CNN ، فقد كشفت أنه لم
يكن هناك
قتال نشط أو مسلحون فلسطينيون
بالقرب من المكان الذي كانت تقف فيه أبو عكلي ،
كانت ترتدي أيضًا سترة تحددها على
أنها تضغط على كل من الجبهة وعلى
ظهرها.
تقرير يوم الإثنين يقول إن الاقتباس حاول
إخفاء الحقيقة وتجنب
المسؤولية والآن هم متصلون  من
أجل تحقيق مستقل من قبل
الولايات المتحدة ، انضم إلينا الآن هي
ابنة أخت شيرين أبو عكلي لينا أبو عكلي
لينا ، شكرًا جزيلاً لك على وجودك معنا
هذا الصباح وأنا آسف جدًا لما
مررت به أنت وعائلتك
هنا كيف حالك أنت وعائلتك
رد فعل العائلة على هذا الخبر ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك على
استضافتي مع عائلتنا ، كما تعلم ، لم
نكن نتوقع أن تتحمل
الحكومة أو الجيش
الإسرائيلي المسؤولية ،
هذا ما كنا نتوقعه في
النهاية ، وبصراحة
كان الأمر كذلك  صعب ، كان الأمر
مزعجًا ومحبطًا للغاية ، وفي
الوقت نفسه
، يحاول البيان فقط
إخفاء الحقيقة وتجنب المسؤولية ،
نحن نعلم الحقيقة ، كما
ذكرتم ، خلصت عدة تقارير استقصائية إلى أن
الجنود الإسرائيليين استهدفوا شيلي وأطلقوا النار عليهم.
وكانت ترتدي سترة واقية
وقد تم تمييزها بشكل واضح بالضغط
من الأمام والخلف
ومع ذلك فقد تمكنوا من التصويب بدقة
بين منطقة  r
خوذة
وسترتها لذلك من المحبط للغاية أنه
حتى يومنا هذا لم يكن هناك أي
مساءلة من الولايات المتحدة إذا كانت الولايات المتحدة
تؤمن حقًا بالمساءلة ،
فلا بد من اتخاذ إجراء
وهذا ما نطلق عليه اليوم أكثر من أي وقت مضى
من أجل تحقيق مستقل للولايات المتحدة
لأن
مجرمي الحرب الإسرائيليين لا يستطيعون
التحقيق في جرائمهم